défi communiste communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables niveau
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
maxime de scopeo et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue sur notre chaîne youtube
aujourd'hui nous sommes plus qu'heureux
de poursuivre notre série d'entrevues
politique avec cette fois ci monsieur
stéphane pieds-noirs sénateur du maine
et loire au programme d'aujourd'hui la
stratégie nucléaire et surtout
énergétique de la france
je laisse tout de suite la parole à mon
compère luca cofondateur de ce propos
pour qu'il pose le décor de ce podcast
merci maxime bonjour à celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à
vous monsieur stéphane pieds noirs
bonjour nous fait le plaisir aujourd'hui
nous accordé cette entrevue pour
discuter ensemble de sujets relatifs à
la politique énergétique de la france
vous êtes vous-même membre de l'opep est
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qui produit régulièrement des rapports
sur les décisions scientifiques du
gouvernement
mais je vous laisserai présenter un peu
plus en détail ce qui est cet office
avant de démarrer l'entrevue et de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet monsieur
pieds noirs je vous laisse vous
présenter brièvement pour celles et ceux
qui nous écoutent
merci à vous de vous pour l'invitation
en présentation je vois simplement dire
je suis donc sénateur de maine et loire
depuis septembre 2017
j'étais auparavant maire d'une commune
du nu d'honneur dont j'aie dans
l'ambiance et des 500 habitants et
vice-président d'une agglomération dans
le riz dans ce cadre je m'occupais
particulièrement des questions d'énergie
les énergies renouvelables aux
particuliers donc c'est tout
naturellement que j'ai souhaité intégrer
l'eau makes alors c'est sans doute pas
raconter des commissions permanentes
pour les députés les sénateurs sont tous
dans une commission dollar à nantes sur
un stand au sénat pour moi c'est laisser
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation les prolongements un petit
peu de mes activités professionnelles
puisque j'étais professeur de
mathématiques eu auparavant
et puis à côté de ça donc il ya cet
office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qu'est ce qu'une structure vraiment
totalement singulière c'est à dire que
c'est la seule structure qui rassemble
député des zélateurs 18 députés et 10
sénateurs avec un équilibre également de
représentation des forces politiques
tant par l'assemblée nationale que c'est
là et se font des parlementaires qui
sont plus particulièrement on va dire
investi sur des questions scientifiques
on retrouve beaucoup de personnes qui
ont des formations scientifiques dans
cet office est alors pour manière
emblématique avait présidé par cédric
villani médaille fields de mathématiques
et j'ai donc premier vice président et
gérard longuet ancien ministre de la
défense
c'est dire le le poids un petit peu
d'aidé des cadres de cette de cet office
est comme son nom l indique il a eu la
permission pour dire de produire des
rapports des réflexions des parfois
délais des choses un peu moins puisque
moins épaisses des petits rapport sur la
politique à long terme dans le domaine
scientifique et l'oenologie de la vie
donc les sujets sont pas restés bassin
depuis là depuis la création de la
baisse en 1983 beaucoup de rapport sur
le nucléaire je crois que ça fera partie
évidemment de l'essentiel de nos
échanges aujourd'hui mais aussi je suis
deg des interrogations sur le sur le
spatial sur la recherche dans le domaine
biomédical là c'est celle
particulièrement raide depuis depuis 18
mois depuis la crise sanitaire que nous
connaissons 1 comment on construit un
vaccin là des choses comme ça et comment
on doit orienter la politique du pays
sur ces thématiques là au fait ces
rapports
là on a la naïveté de croire qu'ils
furent lus par l'exécutif sert donc à
aiguiller les décisions de l'exécutif
dans le domaine scientifique et
technologique
voilà en quelques mots de présentation
de l'aube est écrit et qui n'a pas de
pouvoirs législatifs en tant que telles
sont les vins de produire de la loi ni
dit de réglementation mais en vraiment
de donner à réfléchir de d'aiguillés la
réflexion de deux du gouvernement en
place
c'est tout là toute la beauté je vais
j'ai envie de dire du travail que l'on
haut que l'on produit parce que
il est il pose les bases de décision
pour les décennies à venir et et séance
extrêmement enrichissant d'un point de
vue merci beaucoup monsieur pieds noirs
pour pour ses premières réponses et ses
premiers éléments qui nous permettent
d'entrevoir le travail et le rôle de
l'opex dans dans la réflexion
parlementaire et la réflexion
gouvernementale sur sur l'énergie
j'imagine que vous avez conscience vous
même que le texte est assez méconnu du
grand public
alors merci d'abord pour ses premières
ses premiers éléments d'explication
vous même vous êtes membre de l'opep est
comme vous l'avez dit qu'est ce qui vous
a motivé qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
vous engager politiquement et
personnellement dans cet office et
qu'est ce que cela vous apporte dans
votre vie parlementaire
ce qui m'a poussé à candidater à cet
office 1 puisque comme je le dis il faut
il faut représenter un petit peu les
forces politiques de chaque heure de
chaque assemblée l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat donc c'est c'est en
proportion du poids de chaque groupe
politique
donc l'europe auquel j'appartiens les
républicains sénat une place important
mais mais néanmoins compter donc il faut
il faut candidate et il faut gauche que
le meneur candidature sera retenue au
sein de notre peau et moi ce qui m'a
valu ces a posé cette candidature c'est
vraiment le prolongement de la formation
de ma formation initiale c'est à dire
moi je suis fille j'étais professeur de
mathématiques une formation scientifique
j'ai fait un bac scientifique et et
quelques années d'études heures aidé en
me spécialisant sur les mathématiques
avec un socle scientifique à ses pistes
en assez fort bien sûr images mais pas
seulement la physique et est donc dans
le prolongement je trouvais ça
intéressant de pouvoir comment dire
faire faire profiter de ce vernis
scientifique que je crois pouvoir
disposer et puis évidemment approfondir
j'ai produit un premier rapport il ya
deux ans sur la fin de commercialisation
des véhicules fonctionnant à l'essence
pour faire simple un véhicule habitants
des gaz à effet serre là
si avec une députée du lot via stella
est donc là j'ai découvert des choses
évidemment sur l'univers de la
construction automobile sur les besoins
en terme d'électricité pour alimenter
les véhicules électriques les
conséquences sur sur la formation la
formation initiale et la formation
professionnelle et les conséquences sur
la filière automobile en termes
d'emplois la cdc des choses évidemment
avant des parlementaires que je n'avais
pas forcément en baisse et le fait de
creuser avère en faisant en menant des
auditions il faut dire que ces rapports
sont le fruit d'audition nourris pendant
plus an - un rapport parlementaire à la
lola et c c'est quasiment une année de
travail entre entre 6 et un an et donc
on mène des auditions on est confronté à
d les acteurs qui sont extrêmement au
fait des questions qu'on leur pose est
donc c'est tout ça qui doit alimenter
avec des avis aussi très contradictoires
un très grand tracé parfois et donc
c'est celle de ses sept gros fondation
des amis idées et des idées qui vers
nous on émet un avis on avait les
préconisations des vigilances des points
de vigilance sur telle ou telle
politique ça a été le cas sur sur les
tue le afin des véhicules thermiques à
l'horizon 2040
ce sera le cas sur le rapport à ce trio
nous publierons la semaine bouger alors
justement que le timing de ce podcast
tombe à point nommé puisque dans
quelques jours le pex publiera
ouvertement en accès libre sur internet
son avis sur l'arrêt du projet astrid
donc alors le projet astrid pour les
pour nos auditeurs qui ne connaîtraient
pas c'était ça c'était une sorte prince
était un programme pour développer
inquiète un réacteur nucléaire de
quatrième génération donc basé sur un
recteur rapides refroidis au sodium
voilà si je me trompe pas une thune que
ça et donc ce projet de recherche était
complètement arrêtées par le
gouvernement il y a les gamins ont un
peu plus d'un an et donc l'opex a été
mandaté un il me semble pour
voilà donner son avis en quêté en
quelques heures sur le pourquoi du
comment de l'arrêt de ce projet donc là
à l'heure où on enregistre ce podcast
le projet le rapport de l'opecst ce
n'est pas encore publiée cependant il le
sera sûrement à la date de publication
de ce podcast donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner
voilà deux manières dans les grandes
lignes le point de vue de l'opex sur
l'arrêt de ce projet de recherche de
réacteurs nucléaires
alors vous êtes pour resituer la le
projet astrid a été a été bien écrit je
pense que effectivement dans l'opinion
publique c'est sans doute pas le sujet
qui vient dans la plupart des
conversations des gens en soirée donc il
faut bien comprendre que c'est un projet
de recherche était confiant en 2010 par
le président chirac au cea commissariat
à l'énergie atomique
donc pour pour construire un nouveau
prototype de réacteur nucléaire
je trouve qu'il ya plusieurs sortes de
réacteurs nucléaires la première filière
c'était une figure au gaz étaient les
premiers les premiers réacteurs
nucléaires qui ont été construits dans
les années 60 était sur cette filière là
ils fuient joue sous pompidou dans pour
la les brawn directeur qu'ont été
conçues à partir des années 70 72
la fille qu'elle était retenue cdd des
règles des réacteurs à eau pressurisée
autrement dit le lot était le local au
porteur donc porteur de la matière et
qui refroidit les les électrons dans le
réacteur et les langues
on avait conscience que cette filière là
cette filière des rêves d'un rider à eau
pressurisée avait un temps limité de vie
on évoque un an même si eux il ya aucun
document officiel qui fixe la durée
d'une singulière étant dans un sas est
un c'est une légende urbaine
bien bien relayé par ailleurs dû rester
aux riches
il a été convenu d'admettre abandonné
mais y'a rien qui fixe ça en tout cas il
y avait mes d'évolution de la file
hier vers des réacteurs d'une autre
génération une quatrième génération à le
dire il invente une troisième la
troisième génération c'est la filière
des objets à part le haut bouclé ce
qu'elle connaît un certain nombre de
statuts légaux flamanville notamment on
voit revenir parce que c'est le fruit
quand même date de décision politique ou
d'un ensemble de décisions politiques
mais en tout cas on était vraiment sur
la rai et sur des réacteurs qui avait
vocation à être construit à partir des
années 2040
le prototype était envisagée à environ à
l'horizon 2020 à peu près pour donc les
premiers acteurs opérationnelle à
l'horizon 2015 évidemment la technologie
elle dit faire parce qu'au lieu de
choisir de l'eau pour cal augmenter
l'énergie
on est on est sur deux on est sur du
sodium alors on pourra dire bon pourquoi
pourquoi l'assaut des hommes alors il ya
un avantage c'est que ça ça ne ralentit
pas les électrons donc l'électricité
produit de la chaleur produite n'est pas
est entièrement utilisée en somme si je
peux dire et puis mes mais par contre
les obstacles l'obstacle c'est que le le
sodium réagi à l'eau et à l'air il
s'enflamme où il explose à l'un de ces
au contact de l'un de ces matériaux donc
évidemment c'est plus compliqué que de
l'os pour lui qu'ils aient vu l'eau
comme coca le chanteur maintenant rien
n'est insurmontable mais en réalité ce
projet astrid était la continuité de
soixante dix années d'expérience de la
france dans ce domaine assure les
nouvelles rnr les réacteurs à neutrons
rapides qu'à l'emporter au sodium
parce que c'est les premiers les
premiers prototypes les premiers
réacteurs de m
vos journées des dés les années et les
années cinq ans avec un premier toute
petite puissance mais le recteur
rhapsody était le premier du directeur
phoenix et le réacteur superphénix dont
vous n'avez on a fait véritablement un
temps d'avancé sur cette filière là et
donc président chirac en 2010 ligue
monde c'est l'avenir du nucléaire pour
la france la 4e génération et il faut il
faut enchaîner un programme de recherche
contre ce prototype mais considéré comme
un autre un autre aspect extrêmement
important qu'il faut avoir en tête sur
les rnr c'est la gestion des déchets
évidemment un sujet dont on parle de
nucléaire c'est évidemment important est
qu'il faut pas se voiler la face sur la
le nucléaire produit des déchets thème
des déchets qui sont évidemment
potentiellement dangereux puisqu'ils
sont pour certains rayons des ralentis
voire très des dés les années
dès les années 80 on a investi
lourdement dans le traitement de ces
déchets avec l'usiné de la hague
l'usiné de la hague et la vocation à
reprendre les combustibles usés qui
sortent une première émission en
réacteur à eau pressurisée henry et de
les transformer alors je vais pas entrer
dans le détail des transformations
physiques devant parce que c'est pas mon
métier et puis je pense que c'est pas
forcément le l'objet de deux nouveaux
casques donc d'utiliser ces ces
combustibles usés je dis bien le mont
visibilité et pas des chaînes pour en
faire un autre combustible qu'ils
puissent un type de de tourner à nouveau
dans un radiateur
ce nouveau combustible semos c'est le
combustible mox dont qe2 une combinaison
de d'uranium appauvri missile à trois
bien à combustion puis d'autres d'autres
produits et ce mox à nouveau utilisé
pour une nouvelle évolution n'est même
pas dans tous les réacteurs honda on
avait 58 réacteurs 1056 fermeture de
deux de leurs réacteurs de fessenheim
bien évidemment et donc sur ses 56 rider
seuls 24 aujourd'hui sont capables
d'utiliser seconde usine de boxe tout
simplement parce que c'est c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose que le royaume
combustible uranium
on le met aujourd'hui dans les îles dans
les gares des réacteurs est alors
justement la question c'est pourquoi
dans un tel contexte avec voilà un parc
nucléaire qui vieillit pourquoi avoir
voulu arrêter ce projet de recherche qui
même si voilà il est très technique pour
les gens qui nous écoutent
il faut garder juste de manière
synthétique à l'esprit que c'était voilà
c'était synonyme d'espoir c'était
synonyme d'avenir pour la filière
nucléaire française
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'en fin est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi ce
programme de recherche a été arrêté
c'est une bonne question c'est une bonne
question et comme jeudi vers le multi
recyclage permettait de diminuer les
déchets et même de quasiment 10 oh c'est
à dire on produisait autant de autant de
déchets qu'on en consomme est simple
réducteur mais l'idée c'est ça alors
lille la première la première saison et
qui vient à l'esprit est éloquent le la
première le premier contrat la première
première convention d'objectifs qui
avaient été stimulés par leur président
chirac avec le sénat fixait une un
montant global de 650 millions d'euros
voilà aujourd'hui avec les concours
d'hier
astrid et d'autre d'autres sources de
financement on a une estimation qui est
à 1 milliards 2,1 milliards 3 cd
évidemment conséquent il faut avoir en
tête devant les grandes masses
l'ensemble du parc nucléaire tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui à mobiliser en
euros de vie décent euros actuels 1
quasiment 80 milliards d'euros vous
voyez un milliard trois sur ce programme
uniquement sur ce programme de recherche
c'est quand même conséquent en regard de
ce que l'encens de nulle part nous a
quittés aujourd'hui ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison on va on va
réduire la production le nucléaire et
non qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas à
poursuivre une aventure qui va nous
mener sur la construction de réacteurs
dont on a
potentiellement plus besoin et ça c'est
une analyse on d'aller un peu comment
dire des décisions politiques
il ya un an de revenir longuement mais
qui sont extrêmement lourds de
conséquences parce que moi je n'y crois
pas je suis croire c'est extrêmement
dangereux de se dire on aura plus besoin
du nucléaire à l'horizon 2040 ou 2050
en france en tout cas et dans beaucoup
de pays du monde je vois c'est
totalement illusoire de faire se parler
on vient préciser les choses c'est parce
qu'il se sait pas une décision d'arrêt
totalement des stries parce que que ça
ne soit la fermeture du site c'est à
dire la réutilisation des combustibles
usés pour de nouvelles combustion la
fermeture de six adhérents en gros à
l'iso consommation de combustible
nucléaire
encore une fois c'est inscrit dans la
loi c'est la loi bataille de 1991
rappelé dans une loi complémentaire en
2006 qui fixe qui dit très clairement
que notre pays est inscrit dans le
processus de fermeture le cycle est donc
techniquement d'un pendule législatif
l'exécutif ne peut pas prendre cette
décision d'arrêter la filière de
quatrième génération
parce que cela revient à dire on fait
une croix sur la fermeture du site qui
elle est inscrite dans la loi autrement
dit ça ne peut pas passer sans
consultation du parlement assemblée et
sénat
comme toute inscription dans la loi si
on veut modifier la loi c'est évidemment
possible il revient à l'exécutif de de
le faire mais ça ne peut pas passer sans
consultation du parlement enfants
modification de la loi dans le ballon
sur votre réponse précédente vous
évoquer le sujet très polémique et
j'imagine sur lequel vous travaillez
beaucoup dans vos recherches
scientifiques des déchets nucléaires
moi j'aimerais évoquer plus
particulièrement un autre sujet qui
revient beaucoup quand on parle de
l'énergie nucléaire c'est celui des
accidents nucléaires historiques qui
sont évidemment extrêmement
spectaculaire et qui reste longtemps
dans les mémoires des citoyens à l'image
de ceux de tchernobyl et de fukushima
évidemment vous savez évidemment que
cela génère des peurs des craintes
naturellement chez les citoyens fondées
ou non
au sujet de la sécurité de l'énergie
nucléaire alors que faut-il répondre
selon vous tous selon vous parlerons à
ses doutes que faire pour convaincre
kohl et c'est que les éthiques pour les
rassurer à propos de la sécurité de
l'énergie nucléaire en france
on dit beaucoup de choses sur les
éclairs je lisais genre lisait une
déclaration à un sondage qui faisait
état de deux français sur trois
considéré par exemple que les fumées
existants terre des réacteurs nucléaires
les étés fumée qui émettait des gaz à
effet serre c'est de la vapeur d'eau en
parlant d'une croyance qu'il faut qu'il
faut démontrer ensuite sur le sur
l'horizon sur le risque nucléaire
il n'est pas question de le domaine de
mettre sous le tapis
évidemment on manipule des produits
radioactifs est qui qui peuvent créer un
le le mécanisme à l'intérieur du
réacteur peut s'en va les créer ce qu'on
appelle la fusion nucléaire la fusion
nucléaire c'est ce qui est à l'origine
c'est ce qui potentiellement
l'investissement du projet iter à
cadarache si vous avez entendu parler de
sacs et l'autre l'autre mécanisme
radioactifs qu'on voudrait pouvoir
maîtriser qui serait totalement le graal
jusqu'à on aurait kazyna une énergie
infinie
donc ce qu'on veut éviter à l'intérieur
une hta réacteurs classiques un inconnu
connaissance de la fission nucléaire
c'est c'est éviter l'emballement
or sur les as les incidents les
accidents que vous citez à fukushima
c'est le bal problème c'est pas le
problème en soi de nucléa cessez le feu
namiki qui fait énormément demorand à
tchernobyl c'était une erreur humaine
attendent entre deux de ceux qui depuis
nous écoutons probablement regarder la
série tchernobyl
c'est effarant de voir à quel point on a
négligé des processus de contrôle des
processus
eamon de sécurité partout où le
nucléaire est développée aujourd'hui on
a des autorités de sûreté qui sont de
plus en plus de traque
un lucio shima en a cure si les
conditions sur les radiers c'est à dire
les sages des réacteurs alors on
n'arrête pas d'augmenter la l'exigence
sur la construction des réacteurs sur
l'exploitation des réacteurs est en
réalité il ya un peu d'accidents il n'y
a pas d'accident qui soit lié à une à la
gandhi à une mauvaise maîtrise du
phénomène physique au nucléaire ça ça
n'existe pas et on peut comparer alors
vous faire des analyses sur le nombreux
comme je crois que c'est jean marc
jancovici qui a fait cette analyse sur
le nombre de morts produit par les mines
de charbon où les exploitations de
pétrole sur les plateformes
c'est sans commune mesure on va on est
évidemment c'est laisser ces accidents
sont dramatiques mais c'est sans commune
mesure avec le nombre de décès non c'est
un délit par l'exploitation en
particulier mais des énergies fossiles
et pour rebondir sur le sujet des
déchets qui est évidemment très
préoccupant quand on quand on est
sensible à la question écologique quel
est l'état de la recherche aujourd'hui
en france notamment mais même en règle
générale quel est l'état de la recherche
sur la gestion et éventuellement à long
terme le recyclage des déchets
nucléaires alors sur la gestion on a on
à l'andra qui est la structure qui qui
est chargé de superviser la gestion on a
on a 1 comment dire un plan national de
gestion des matières qu'un hacker fait
l'objet d'un débat public verra tout ça
est quand même plutôt voire très
transparent ça sur la gestion des
déchets on a le projet cigéo dont vous
avez entendu parler sans l'homme qui qui
est un projet à but l'un d'eux consiste
à enfouir à 450 mais en couches
géologiques profondes et très stable
des déchets qui sont vitrifiés et qui
vont qui vont être stockés là pendant
des centaines d'années sur la recherche
on a plein de en fait on a plein de
pistes quand je parlais des réacteurs de
quatrième génération
il ya plein d'autres possibilités pour
faire suite au gpm y compris d'ailleurs
les petits réacteurs qui ont qui aurait
l'avantagé
les small le directeur les smr il
faudrait qu'on pourrait développer dans
des temps des usines qui ferait en effet
de série et qu'on pourrait donc
installée de lysine sur des sites
directement et vous demande comment fuir
ce qui permet à l'inter de sécurité
évidemment d'être d'être à la fois donc
il ya pleins pleins d'objets de
recherche dans la vraie question qu'il
faut qu'on se pose elles sont vraiment
poursuivre l'aventuré glaire et pas
seulement en france pour le monde entier
ou est ce qu'on considère les jours on
va revenir à la bougie
ma question
vraiment il faut qu'on se pose les
bonnes questions et qu'on ne peut pas
abandonner une filière qui est
extrêmement promet 2 0 non seulement
prouvé 2 2 mais qu'a fait ses preuves
[Musique]
alors vous
dizier justement que la grande question
c'est est ce qu'on souhaite continuer
l'aventuré nucléaire ou non
moi j'aurais envie de dire c'est un
petit peu compliqué de connaître la
position du gouvernement aujourd'hui on
a l'impression qu'il arrive pas à
prendre de décision
on est dans un en même temps parce que
d'un côté on entend un président et
certains ministres qui nous parle du
nucléaire comme quelque chose dans
lequel il faut investir dans le calcaire
bon là un secteur qui est prometteur
puis l'autre côté on a des ministres
comme madame barbara pompiers qui ont du
mal à admettre que le nucléaire devrait
enfin est nécessaire à la transition
écologique on a aussi à l'arrêt de
fessenheim on à leucate flamanville
également donc comment vous de voix de
votre point de vue parlementaires qu'il
y avait qui avait étudié ces questions
là comment vous expliquez ce seul
véritable en même temps macro niant ont
dit deux choses différemment en même
temps et c'est super mais c'est
difficile de vous demander d'expliquer
ça parce que je sais c'est assez
incompréhensible en réalité comme vous
l'avez dit on à une forme de de
procrastination d'ailleurs du président
la règle du un google fait chez un des
fonds dans le monde dans le cadre du
plan de relance sur la recherche dans le
nucléaire et puis ils étaient attendues
sur le réseau en dix ans alors que sa
visite au creusot disant on va forcément
aller se faire la construction de 2 3 1
3 paires de pair ce qu'on a entendu et
puis en fait il n'y a pas décision et on
voit bien on comprend bien c'est que
c'est surtout pas le moment de faire ses
annonces la broye laurent parce que on
est à quelques mois d'une élection
présidentielle
un l'avenir énergétique et économique
d'ailleurs du pays
l'indépendance énergétique du pays vaut
mieux que la procrastination comme ça de
de plusieurs mois en réalité il est
urgent de prendre des décisions tout
simplement parce on a ce qu'on appelle
un léger falaise j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure des des 58 réacteurs qui avaient
été construits quasiment en haut qu'en
l'espace de 15 à 20 ans évidemment si
son conjoint quasiment tous en même
temps ils vont arriver en fin de vie
quasiment tous en même temps donc on a
eu des périodes où on aurait dû prendre
des décisions
au début des années 2000 ensuite on a eu
des décisions contraires avec des
accords sur le thème d'accords
politiques qui sont restés stables et
aujourd'hui à nouveau on suspend le
clame astrid qui condamne la fermeture
de chine comme j'ai expliqué qu'il est
inscrit dans la loi et on ne propose
rien d'autre
en compensation si je puis dire en tout
cas on a osé mais pour aller où la
question c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
comment on va produire notre électricité
on a tous seuls on voit tout ce que les
besoins en électricité sont en train de
croître de manière considérable
d'ailleurs on a de ce point de vue là en
france une espèce de schizophrénie un
peu un peu inquiétante puisque et puis
comme l'angleterre l'allemagne bidi font
va augmenter de 60 70 80 % de
consommation d'électricité à l'horizon
en france on dit 20% à la route
donc on est à la fois face à un mur de 2
d'augmentation de la consommation
électrique notamment avec la mobilité
électrique et je suis ce qui constitue
notre 70% je rappelle notre production
électrique d'origine nucléaire qui est
en train de s'éteindre jeu
je comprends pas comment cet impératif
là ne constitue pas pour l'exécutif pour
le gouvernement une obligation de faire
des annonces et parce qu'on sait que la
construction d'armateurs ça il faut il
faut dix ans pour faire pour faire
émerger un réacteur où qu'il soit en
capacité de produire de l'électricité
élection présidentielle ou pas il
fallait qu'il fallait prendre les
décisions durant ce cas car leur
endurance
c'est dans également donc moi je ne fume
pas adra pour ménager le thème d'une
susceptibilité de lobby antinucléaire
qui constitue encore une barre de une
barre de la majorité présidentielle
certaines sont sans doute là une
explication politique on peut on peut
trouver alors pour ma part je vais
peut-être un peu plus polémiques
l'explication politique j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut la trouver dans
la politique étrangère
vous évoquez là l'angleterre et
l'allemagne quand on voit que
l'allemagne d'un côté refusent que le
nucléaire soit considérée comme une
énergie verte comme c'est le cas
ailleurs déjà en inde en chine aux états
unis et voilà a aussi participé a motivé
la fermeture de fessenheim puisque c'est
une centrale qui se trouve à la
frontière franco-allemande est ce qu on
ne peut pas penser d'une certaine
manière que l'allemagne pèse quand même
beaucoup voire dicté par moments la
politique énergétique française tout
particulièrement en termes de nucléaire
mais bien sûr alors le la politique
énergétique de l'allemagne évidemment
depuis sous merkel a été très fortement
soumise aux influences des bdr allemands
qui font une part de leur religion y
venir on aimerait entendre des
responsables pendant cela en france
d'hier le nucléaire c'est parti la
solution on a b on a des les politiques
et golo qui commence à voir ce discours
d'allemagne oui le poids de l'allemagne
pèse il faut pas oublier que le père
s'était mis collaboration
franco-allemande
c'est une collaboration franco-allemande
à la base et que du coup les les normes
qui se sont durcies sur la construction
de ses pairs qui nous avons dit à des
difficultés que l'on connaît sont liées
à des augmentations d'exigence en cours
de construction
elle avance ici en cours de construction
d'une maison vous augmentez le cahier
des charges durcissait le cahier des
charges vous allez avoir un allongement
des délais vous allez avoir une
augmentation du cours tout le monde peut
comprendre ça c'est ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur le père il
yad'autres d'autres volets l'addiction
en terme de
une perte de savoir faire bien sûr on
peut parler des soudures à sur le maire
de flamanville par exemple merkel on
voit bien qu'il ya eu un durcissement
des conditions imposées par l'allemagne
à la france dans le cadre de la
construction de ces au père qui fait
qu'on n'y arrive pas on n'arrive pas à
tenir dans les délais on n'arrive pas à
tenir le coup
donc oui vous avez raison le poids de
l'allemagne mais mais ça ça fléchi un
petit peu et on sait bien que leurs gros
problème c'est la production d
électricité dans des centrales à charbon
les émissions dans la production de
l'électricité dans le charbon c'est
c'est cinq fois plus émetteurs de co2
que le nucléaire un faux clame le savoir
donc la solution pas seulement en
allemagne en pologne et dans plein
d'autres pays ça passe par la
construction de réacteurs nucléaires et
éventuellement des comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure des petits d'espoir le
modérateur même et batteur l'inde a fait
le choix par exemple de construire 6
aubert de grandes de grande puissance
parce que les besoins électriques de ce
pays et de tous les pays émergents en
croissance exponentielle c'est évident
donc il faut qu'on ait le courage
simplement de dire oui le d'éclairs
combattre ensemble de risques mais nous
vous en donnons les moyens de les
maîtriser la sn lagence l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire en france est
extrêmement - dieuze extrêmement
exigeante sur le contrôle de nos
installations
je croise à développer à l'échelle
mondiale il ya aucune raison de voir une
peur excessive de deux êtres du maxime
vient d'évoquer le sujet de la politique
étrangère et plus particulièrement
européenne
on a également lu des considérations
purement énergétique et scientifique
maintenant j'aimerais si vous le voulez
monsieur pieds noirs qu'on se penche un
petit peu sur l'aspect économique de la
filière nucléaire puisque il est vrai
qu'on entend de nombreux écologistes qui
promeuvent le développement des énergies
renouvelables afin de créer comme ils
disent des centaines de milliers
d'emplois en france
je me souviens particulièrement de la
france en sont mises en 2017 qui
défendra cette position en déclarant qu'
il pouvait éventuellement y avoir deux à
trois millions d'emplois en développant
les énergies renouvelables en france
alors
en comparaison la seule énergie
nucléaire non pas peut-être pas
suffisamment
s'ils sont si l inverse ont développé un
petit peu plus nos énergies
renouvelables à l'échelle nationale
quelle est votre opinion sur ce sujet
monsieur je voudrais bien où mon opinion
sur la qualité des experts de la france
est soumise dans le domaine de
l'économie mais je suis pas sûr parce
que ça m'intéresse mais franchement au
bout du monde
il faut quand même se dire que c'est le
consommateur anglais on a une exit et
qui aujourd'hui est deux à trois fois
moins cher pour le client particulier qu
en allemagne par exemple la filière
nucléaire
c'est 200 rien 220 mille emplois directs
et indirects
rien qu'en france c'est le croit mais
l'entreprise moi je veux bien qu'on mène
tout ça par terre mais quand la spar
alors de minéraux emplois dans le
domaine des énergies renouvelables jeux
je n'y crois moi j'ai un chiffre en tête
j'ai deux chiffres en tête c'est ce qu'a
coûté le parc nucléaire aujourd'hui en
15 ans 80 milliards d'euros la
construction des 52 58 réacteurs 80
milliards d'euros on a investi dans les
nerfs dans l'éolien et le photovoltaïque
sur les 15 dernières années 150
milliards d'euros le double pour
produire 15% de l'électricité alors que
alors que le nucléaire produit 70%
il ya quelque chose qui va pas voir ça
encore une fois dans tous les temps tous
les scénarios du logiciel que je sois
l'académie de médecine l'académie des
sciences qui a produit un rapport là le
8 juillet
il ya quelques jours en disant il faut
du nucléaire ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas de nerfs voyez on n'est pas sur des
scénarios 100% nucléaire alors que de
l'autre côté si je puis dire on nous dit
il faut des défauts des scénarios 100%
en plein air mais c'est pas le modèle de
la france certains pays tant mieux pour
eux la norvège profite d'éléments
naturels extrêmement favorable pour
produire de l'électricité n'est
totalement des gares lauder et les
chutes d'eau l'hydraulique en norvège
c'est 95% les mensonges de la réduction
des déficits et tant mieux lui tant
mieux pour eux on a fait ça
il faut arrêter de se dire qu'avec avec
gloire devant et avec donne à notre
ensoleillé en france on va produire de
l'électricité ça n'est pas vrai
d'ailleurs là la première première er en
france céline urdens et l'hydraulique
c'est parce qu'on l'a aussi on a su
exploiter nos barrages on a beaucoup de
rivières et de fleuves en france on l'a
on sait quand on s'appuie dessus nos
produits beaucoup d'électricité rée ça
mais de deux dire on va tourner tout
raser et puis vous allez voir c'est
formidable on aura deux millions de
personnes qui vont travailler avec les
honneurs c'est pas possible il faut être
réaliste un petit peu et puis et puis il
faut il faut s'appuyer sur ce qui
fonctionne
chose qui est économiquement stable
costaud robuste et c'est le cas du
nucléaire
mais encore une fois pas de scénario
100% nucléaire parce que c'est un
pilotable le moment où les événements
produisent au moment où le vent souffle
fort est un peu fort également on peut
réduire c'est facile de piloter la
production de l'électricité par le
nucléaire c'est totalement pilotable ce
n'est pas une une éolienne ou un panneau
photovoltaïque donc les deux sont
complémentaires
il faut pas il faut arrêter d'opposer
l'un et l'autre tous les scénarios
désormais à s'accordent à dire qu'ils
font à la fois du nucléaire est désert
c'est intéressant que vous ne soyez pas
dans cette posture dogmatique justement
d'opposer l'un et l'autre parce qu'on
voit dans certains camps politiques en
particulier dans des gens qui se
réclament de l'écologie des gens qui
font du dogmatisme qui oppose l'un et
l'autre vous qui voit là devaient
côtoyer d'autres parlementaires qui
appartiennent pour le moment à des
groupes affiliés à europe écologie les
verts comment vous comment vous
expliquer qu'elles sont vous dans vos
interactions peut-être avec ses
parlementaires là comment eux explique
aussi c'est ce refus de voilà d'avoir
recours au nucléaire pour participer à
la transition écologique alors même que
le giec dans son dernier rapport
indiquait que voilà il fallait compter
que leclerc serait un outil qui
indispensable indispensable c'est le mot
qui est utilisé à la transition est
collé comment vous vous l'expliquer par
cette posture dogmatique de certains
écologique qui refusent en bloc tout
recours au nucléaire
j'ai déjà dit il ya depuis depuis les
années 60 un lobby antinucléaire est
extrêmement fort qui diffuse des
informations qui sont pas dans son
patient six films en blu ray kiki qui
sortent sur les contre vérités j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure des fumées lowa ses
choix d'aider des réacteurs nucléaires
ils sont uniquement la vapeur d'eau sur
la longévité des réacteurs 40 ans avait
écrit nulle part dans aucun document
officiel on a fixé ça s'est il s'appuie
là-dessus il s'appuie évidemment sur des
images qui sont extrêmement choquant
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé à
tchernobyl loi ouais faut que je suis va
mais jamais on revient au coeur au coeur
de l'explication scientifique comme j'ai
tenté de de l'éphèbe de le faire tout à
l'heure et puis il ya les accords
politiques
j'aime parler de super phénix était un
acteur sodium à l'époque a été arrêté en
98 mais une tournée pour des raisons
politiques d'accord politique entre ce
qu'on appelait la gauche plurielle à
l'époque
et puis le et puis les écologistes qui
était qui était au gouvernement 98
témoignait notamment de la même classe
en un an 2000 heures de leur donner deux
quinquas date de françois hollande en a
décidé un tour edouard bouyé de réduire
la production d'électricité par le
nucléaire de 75 à 50%
c'est à dire un tiers en moins donc on
s'est dit tiens tiens ça sonne bien et
on va on a à peu près 60 tracteurs 58 ou
à faire en tant qu'homme et allemands on
va réduire en faire les femmes ah ça
c'est bien on va faire au moins aussi
bien de l'allemagne instaurée
compétition est bête et méchante
consommer comme ça est donc vain barak
devant moi ça fait un tiers en moins
15 c'est pas pour ça qu'on fait de la
photo fait de la politique prospective à
à 20 30 50 ans sur ces bases là enfin
faut pas s'étonner ça donne des
résultats qui soient totalement stupide
donc je conserve sur des sur des non
voyance sur des fausses informations
comme des informations qui ne sont pas
scientifiquement robuste et puis sur les
accords politiques une combinaison de 12
à fait qu'on arrive à une politique
énergétique à bail qui n'a pas de
politique le nom en fait hein c'est
juste donner des petits arrangements
entre amis yeux assez vos histoires
d'ailleurs ses amis alors oui mais quand
je t'en prie aime cas d'un doublage
histoire basée sur cette question des
écologistes qui m'interpelle parce que
comment vous avez essayé d'esquisser un
petit peu une explication sur cette
position qui est difficilement
compréhensible de la part des de
certains écologistes
j'imagine qu'ils sont qui ne sont pas
rigoureux parfois sur le sur le plan
scientifique ils ne sont pas par passion
mais peut-être est-ce que vous pouvez
imaginer des conflits d'intérêts des
collisions avec des lobbys qui qui
promeuvent ou qui défendent le
développement de certaines énergies
renouvelables puisque puisque j'imagine
que cela ne se défend pas seulement sur
le plan scientifique mais par des
collusions avec des centres d'intérêts
différents
non je veux franchement je le ferais
plutôt parce que c'est là en revanche
parce qu'on voit bien c'est plutôt le
phénomène inverse les mois bien que en
enclenchant le mouvement où il vient ce
qui se passe sur l'éolien particulier en
ce moment en france
il a quand même un vent de refus si je
fais lire c'est le fort alors des élus
lors des habitants et la raison c'est
qu'en fait les normes ont à faire des
trotteurs des promoteurs immobiliers qui
arrive dans dans une commune qui qui
font un peu miroiter monts et merveilles
à des élus en disant voilà ce que vous
allez tout frais et ce à sa charge
sanogo mendiants ça ne procède pas d'une
démarche écolo un peu plus tôt une
démarche capitaliste d'investissement
sur un territoire de rentabilité et
éventuellement à bien on arrive à
des élus barré par des retombées
fiscales et économiques sur leur
territoire donc je pense pas que je fais
là ce procès aux écolos dont je pense
que vraiment certains se sont dit le
nucléaire il n'en faut pas parce que
c'est lorsque ces salles parce que ça
fait des morts mais oui mais les mines
de charbon
on est en train d'installer en pologne
condos
on ouvre je crois une mine de charbon de
la semaine dans le monde en ce moment
c'est à dire in fine gueule ça ça ça ça
n'a pas l'air de défriser les écolos
alors c'est un scandale en terre à la
fois de pollution et de ris et nantes
rien les mines de charbon seront plus ou
moins à l'heure actuelle il y en a
toujours des baisers mouvement n'a pas
changé et donc on ad on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'essais du top 60 x 60 morts
dans l'autre lui dans le monde
c'est énorme donc voilà je pense que
dans ce soit celle du conflit d'intérêt
ou de la double intérêt legault regarder
dans des promoteurs d'éolien ou une
photo ld je lui donne pas sur cette
piste là alors donc là c'est intéressant
d'avoir le point de vue un peu plus
politique de de l'homme les républicains
parce qu'on puisse on a entendu les
quelques quelques jours dans la presse
que les publicains serait climato
sceptiques comme ce monsieur le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriel à table
c'est intéressant de voir qu'il y à des
républicains qui s'intéressent au climat
maintenant voilà pour se réinscrire un
petit peu dans le thème et pour conclure
un petit peu cette entrevue
quant aux rapports d'astrid qu'elles
sont au final les recommandations que
fait cet office au gouvernement quant à
la stratégie à adopter vis-à-vis du
nucléaire et de l'énergie dans les
grandes lignes les recommandations que
monsieur villani monsieur longuet vous
mêmes et entre autres voilà donnant au
gouvernement sur l'aspect que je batte
aux celtics étaient assez assez risible
en réalité parce qu'on nous reprochait
de ne pas avoir mis à l'essai était de
mettre dans la constitution cette
constitution garantissant la
préservation de l'environnement
si vous porte ouverte à des contentieux
à m
on a du travail parlementaire me
d'autres d'autres termes qui agit pour
la préservation du climat très bien
n'est pas même pas garantie sur sur les
préconisations du rapport d'israël sera
publié prochainement
la première c'est me rebelle mais que
fait donc on suspend un stream est
remplacé par quoi la fermeture belgique
est ce que ça donne le lien est ce qu on
a un nouvel axe de recherche alors
termes d'attractivité aussi pour nos
étudiants ou nos chercheurs de nos
ingénieurs
c'est quoi le c'est moi le palliatif si
on veut arrêter street par exemple pour
des raisons économiques il qu'on nous le
dise mais est ce qu'on fait on renonce à
notre cerveau tordu si on fait comme les
états unis ça veut dire qu'on produit
des déchets on les stocke sur dans des
déserts on a un peu moins d air en
france veulent un écho aux états unis
c'est la première des préconisations
c'est ça c'est par quoi remplace-t-on
astrid
si vous voulez l'arrêter vous faites
quoi à la place il ne le dit pas on peut
arrêter de travailler sur le nucléaire
du futur il faudra du nucléaire dans le
futur le parlement je suis sûr que si on
a un débat éclairé là dessus a semblé
laisser là on aura une forme de
consensus sur sur la cheminée et
l'orientation à prendre sur le nucléaire
dans ce trailer on remplace par mois
donc il faut un vrai va stratégie pour
les décennies à la mer sur le sur la
recherche le nucléaire du futur
c'est la seule à la préconisation numéro
un
et puis et puis la modulation du
parlement en veux pas je sais bien que
la mode et a aidé à jupiter puissant
mais la mode ça ne peut pas être de
passer outre les prérogatives du
parlement qui est jusqu'à preuve du
contraire doit faire la loi et si la loi
doit être changée
c'est également au parlement de le faire
et pas un président l'argument -
gouvernement on apprend par all she
geste il les lit ma dose expliqué
d'ailleurs sur le totalement raccord sur
ce point là ne pas aller sur le
nucléaire est une énergie totalement
décarbonés quasiment décarbonés seagram
entre seagram et 12 grammes co2 au au
kilowattheure produit
c'est au contraire il faut aller vers
cette énergie là si on est
si on ôte convaincu que le dérèglement
climatique et les droits que vous et
c'est mon cas et dans ce cas là il faut
se donner les moyens il faut fermer les
usines de production d'électricité par
les mines les mine de charbon est allé
dans le nucléaire ça ce serait vraiment
responsable et c'est un message
d'ailleurs mondial c'est pas un message
sur la sur la france ea france doit
profiter de son ide en chine des années
70 pour un nouveau bien être être moteur
dans cette danse au développement du
nucléaire à travers le monde
non on ne peut pas se permettre de dire
à certains pays émergents dans vous
n'avez pas loin d'y développer parce que
ça va ça va conduire à une consommation
d'électricité
donc on ne peut pas vous promettre à 6
tous les pays ont le droit au
développement et où ça doit
s'accompagner par des moyens de
production sur les garonnais est donc la
solution c'est l'une des souris dont une
partie de la solution c'est le nucléaire
alors pour conclure cette entrevue
monsieur pieds noirs je vais vous poser
une dernière question assez rapides donc
y qui exige une question une réponse
pardon concise vous avez évoqué le rôle
important que vous voulez accordé au
parlement sur les questions notamment
énergétiques mais sur les questions de
politique maintenant avec le général
quel serait selon vous le rôle que
pourrait jouer également les citoyens
sur ces questions énergétiques et ce
qu'ils auraient un rôle à jouer est ce
que cela pourrait passer par des
consultations citoyennes
alors les consultations elles sont elles
sont indispensables
on a parlé rapidement tout à l'heure du
de six géants tels que le stockage en
couche géologique profonde du siv est
l'objet un travail énorme avec la
population vous imaginez bien que
accueillir ce type de projet sur son
territoire
c'est évidemment pas perçu de manière
extrêmement favorable donc il ya une
large consultation pourrait expliquer qu
est ce que c'était que quels étaient les
les produits qu'elle est stocké dans
quelles conditions qu'est ce que c'est
que la vitrification pourquoi on
remettait ça ici et bailleurs ça c'est
la consultation citoyenne
moi je suis il faut associer évidemment
le plus largement possible la population
lorsqu'il ya des des décisions comme ça
qui les concernent sur leur territoire
sur leur image en revanche les décisions
stratégiques les décisions législatives
elles appartiennent à l'exécutif elles
appartiennent probablement moi je suis
un bref arrêt de ne devoir on se réfère
de manière systématique aux 150 de la
consultation citoyenne
c'est bien d'avoir cette réflexion
pourquoi il faut pas que ça devienne il
faut que ça s'impose au travail du
parlement
c'est pas le parlement qui doit suivre
la consultation citoyenne convention que
ça que ça fasse partie des éléments de
réflexion
aucun sujet là dessus mais vous parler
assez drôlement et bien écoutez merci
beaucoup
bon c'est pour ces réponses monsieur
monsieur le sénateur merci d'avoir pris
le temps voilà c'est aussi important on
peut
je pense qu'au xxième siècle on peut
aussi imaginer que youtube et les
podcasts peuvent être aussi un moyen de
pour les les parlementaires voilà
d'exposer leurs travaux et leurs pensées
au alors concitoyens je remercie
également le cas en sont qu il aurait
été très difficile d'organiser cette
entrevue
j'invite tous nos auditeurs allez lire
s'il le souhaite
les deux premières parties des articles
de scopeo chronique atomique sur le las
l'état la stratégie nucléaire française
donc de deux articles écrits par
moi-même qui retrace qui donne un peu
plus de contexte et j'invite également
les auditeurs à aller consulter le
rapport de l'opecst ce qui sera publié
dans les prochains jours qui est
peut-être déjà publié à l'heure vous
écoutez cette entrevue mais voilà une
chose est sûre ce rapport de l'opecst ce
c'est un moyen pour nous les citoyens
aussi d'avoir un oeil un peu plus clair
sur ce que la politique du gouvernement
sur le pourquoi du comment de ces de ces
décisions relatives à la politique
énergétique et même si des fois c'est un
petit peu fastidieux voilà je pense que
le temps qu'a pris monsieur pieds noirs
aujourd'hui prouve que l'opex et est un
gage de qualité et j'ai moi-même très
hâte de lire ce rapport
donc merci une nouvelle fois monsieur
pieds noirs merci à vous merci merci
beaucoup monsieur monsieur pioneer pour
7 introduit passionnante sur sur la
politique énergétique de façon générale
mais on est bon c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus centré sur l'énergie
nucléaire qui est un sujet sur lequel on
peut dire tout et son contraire vous
avez eu un un discours très scientifique
très rationnel sur ce sujet et j'ai
trouvé ça extrêmement pertinent et
agréable à écouter
merci pour vos réponses honnêtes précise
avec beaucoup de clarté
j'invite nos éditeurs a su ne travaille
également sur ce qu au plus haut point
notre site internet à consulter nos
articles et nos autres entrevues
politique sur notre chaîne youtube
scopeo l'observatoire politique
le supplément encore un grand merci et
nous vous souhaitons une bonne
continuation dans tout votre travail
scientifique et parlementaires merci
également à voir